Okay, so moving right along, we are going to use the retargeted characters for crowd
simulation.
So these characters will randomly move from point A to point B within a designated region,
useful for crowd scenes because we can record the results.
And then there's no need to re-simulate over and over again.
Once we record, we can reuse it however we want.
So first thing is to set up the navigation region.
And let's go to Unreal to do that.
So I'm going to look at the place actors tab in the top left.
And I will just type in the word nav because we're going to bring in the nav mesh bounds
of volume.
Now we don't see anything green yet.
And sometimes if I don't make sure that my viewport is active, this next hotkey to make
the navigation region visible doesn't always work.
So you know, just kind of click around in there and make sure the viewport is active.
Then you should be able to hit P. And look, we are now seeing the happy green region for
our crowds to walk around.
So it's a very small space right now, but we can adjust it.
We can scale up the region.
Let's make it a bit larger.
Keep going a bit more until we are happy with the results.
So something like that.
Either way, to see the region, if we can't remember P for pathfinding or P for navigation,
you can go up to show in the viewport.
And then you'll notice that navigation has the P hotkey.
It will tell you, or you can just click on the checkbox either way.
And looking at the stairs right here, I know the green slope looks a little different than
the stairs, but the characters will actually be able to go up the stairs and onto the platform.
So there's that.
And then there's also another volume I want to point out to you.
It's called the nav modifier volume.
So let's say I don't want these crowd agents getting near the main actors of a scene, or
maybe I don't want them bottlenecking in this narrow hallway right here between the cube
and the platform.
So I'll drag in the nav mesh volume.
And let me move it over.
Okay.
And make sure it's low enough so that it's actually intersecting with the ground.
Just hit F to zoom in on that volume and I'll just adjust it a little bit.
So if I don't have it low enough, then it's not going to do anything.
That path is still green down there.
But now we're good.
And if I want to, I can make that a little more narrow and then more of this top portion
of the cube is available.
Something like that.
You can tweak it more.
Now I'm going to use the term agent and crowd interchangeably, so we're going to make a
class for the agent, crowd, extra that's roaming around in the scene.
And to do that, we are going to duplicate the third person character class that already
exists and then we're going to strip out a bunch of behavior so it doesn't listen to
the user input.
We want it to have a different random motion that we will set up later.
So let's go back to Unreal.
If I go to the third person BP folder and then go to blueprints and then if I click
on the third person character and control W to duplicate, I'm going to call this crowd
character.
So we've got the main third person character.
We now also have a crowd character.
Double click on your new blueprint class and let's dock the tab up at the top.
And you should be in the event graph tab.
If for some reason you're in the construction script or the viewport, just move over to
the event graph tab and you should see all of these notes.
And again, we're not doing a ton of coding.
We're just going to delete things and we're simplifying this class.
And I'm just going to left marquee drag over all of these nodes because we don't want the
mouse or the keyboard to be moving our crowd.
So I'm just going to hit delete.
Yep.
I know that might seem a little scary, but it's fine.
Delete all of those.
And then if I go over to the viewport tab, we don't really need a camera for these crowd
characters.
So you can delete the camera boom and the follow camera.
Delete both of those.
And you could also delete these two variables.
We are not going to be using those either.
So delete and delete base lookup rate and then compile and save.
And then one more thing to point out while I'm in this class, there's this component
called character movement.
Now this is what enables different movement modes like running and flying and swimming
and walking.
And there's a lot of other features too.
And the one I want to point out, it has to do with movement avoidance.
And so this feature is called RVO avoidance.
And if we turn that on, we could control how far away the characters are before they try
to avoid each other.
So right now it's if we were to turn this on, it would be 500 centimeters and then the
characters would turn and move away from each other.
And you can crank up the avoidance weight and then the characters will really run away
much more fervently.
And it's useful for games, especially if you have an enemy character, things like that.
But for the purposes of what we're doing, which is more cinematic, we're actually okay
with the behavior that we're going to be setting up.
But I just wanted to point that out to you.
You might need it in the future.
Okay, so we made a class for the crowd character.
In the next video, we're going to make another blueprint class.
And this is going to specify the movement from point A to point B along the navigation mesh.
So let's do that.